hi i'm justin rezas and i'll be talking
to you about our work interaction
preserving compilers for secure
computation
this is a joint work with nico dutchling
vippo guyal and giulio malavolta
in this work we're concerned with the
problem of secure multi-party
computation
where all parties provide a private
input
and then they get the output
and the security guarantee we want is no
information about the input is revealed
except for the output
we are further concerned with the
setting where all but one party can be
corrupted
and we still want
security to hold in this setting
looking at the communication complexity
of
the work over the years
yao's garbled original garbled circuit
construction scales with the size of
both inputs as well as the
size of the circuit which it's computing
more recently
works have come up with alice or bob
optimized protocols
these are two-party computation
protocols where the communication is
fully independent of one party's input
another advantage of these protocols is
they are constant round protocols
another approach to reducing the
communication complexity is to use fully
homomorphic encryption
using this approach
it is possible to actually
get communication which is completely
independent of both inputs for certain
functions
you do have to pay a cost um
according to the communication
of an insecure protocol which computes
the function
and using off-the-shelf current tools
you will incur a multiplicative
polynomial blow up in terms of the
security parameter lambda
another downside of these approaches is
that they add two additional rounds to
the protocol
in this work we're concerned with
um
constructing multi-party computation
protocols where the communication
complexity is independent
of
the size of the inputs
lower bounds show that we can't always
achieve this
but for a rich class of functions we can
[Music]
achieve
communication complexity which is
lower
than both inputs
as an example let's consider
combinatorial games
if we were
say to compare two different chess ais
it would be very
cost
intensive to simply communicate the ais
because they might be very large
however playing chess only requires the
next move to be communicated
another example of a function which can
be
computed in
much less
communication than
the size of the inputs is
yao's millionaire problem
um
and in this problem
two parties or two millionaires want to
figure out who has the higher salary but
they don't want to reveal their exact
salary
uh we're going to consider the insecure
version of this protocol for a moment
where the parties don't care if their
salaries are revealed
the naive solution to this is to simply
send your salary to the other party
and they can do the computation
however this is linear in the in at
least one party's input size
randomized algorithms however can do
communication complexity and rounds
which are logarithmic in the input size
and there are more examples of such
functions from the communication
complexity literature
in this work we consider the problem of
taking an n round insecure protocol for
functionality f
and designing a secure protocol for f
with roughly the same communication
complexity both in terms of
the number of bits exchanged and the
number of rounds
this result will allow us to lift
results from communication complexity
literature
directly into the secure computation
setting
we're going to start off by considering
the case of security against semi-honest
adversaries which will follow the
protocol and try to learn
extra information by examining the
messages
and we're going to do this in the common
reference string model where the parties
all start with a reference string which
is sampled by a trusted party and known
by all parties
assuming the hardness of the circular
learning with errors problem
we can achieve this
uh we do have a communication overhead
of a little of one times
the communication complex worst case
communication complexity of the insecure
protocol but asymptotically this is
simply going to be an additive overhead
rather than a multiplicative overhead as
we saw previously
we do have um some polynomial dependence
on the last message
the depth of the output circuit and the
size the output
as well as the security parameter lambda
however
previous work has shown that overcoming
this dependency will require some form
of program obfuscation
for the case of two parties we get a
perfect round preserving compiler which
takes end round protocols onto end round
protocols
but for the case of m parties we do need
to add an extra round
however
making the additional assumptions of
extractable witness encryption and
succinct non-interactive arguments of
knowledge
we can get a perfect round-preserving
compiler for the more general case of m
parties
we do incur a slight increase in the
communication overhead you'll notice
that the polynomial term
on the last line
now has an m in it which is the number
of parties
given these results a natural next
question is whether or not we can get
security against malicious adversaries
which might
they can act arbitrarily and don't have
to follow the protocol at all
and we want this in the plane model
where we don't have a common reference
string
assuming simulation extractable snarks
in addition to the
previous assumptions we can lift both of
our results into this setting
at only the cost of adding
a polynomial blow up to the second
message
of the protocol
and we do have a minimum round
requirement of 4 here
due to some lower bounds on
mpc
which needs to be secure against
malicious adversaries in the plain model
at the heart of our
communication complexity improvements
is uh some results for multi-keto
linearly or fully homomorphic encryption
assuming uh
the hardness of learning with errors
there exists a ciphertext rate one
multi-key linearly homomorphic
encryption scheme
if we make an additional circularity
assumption we can turn this into a rate
one multi-key fully homomorphic
encryption scheme
and a fully homomorph multi-key folio
homework encryption scheme will allow
each party to select its own key
then
any ciphertexts
under any of those keys can be computed
on under
all of the keys
rate 1 is important because
asymptotically if we encrypt a message
the resulting ciphertext will be roughly
the same size
as a starting point let's consider a
basic
mpc protocol
which uses multi-key
fully homomorphic encryption
in the first round we uh each of the
parties will sample
a public key and they will broadcast
this along with the first message
of um the insecure protocol which is
encrypted under those keys
in the subsequent rounds from 2 to n
they will complete the insecure protocol
using
or underneath the hood of the folio
morph encryption
um and in round n plus one
using the tran encrypted transcript that
they've just computed they will compute
their encrypted outputs
finally and around n plus two
uh each of the parties will partially
decrypt the outputs from the other
parties
and once this is done they can locally
recombine these partially decrypted
outputs in order to recover their own
output
there are a few improvements that we can
make to this
basic construction
first we can shave off one or two rounds
using secure computation tools
we do need to be careful not to increase
the communication too much with round
reductions because typically uh round
reduction tools do increase the
communication
however we are able to do this with just
a small overhead
the second improvement that we can make
is to use a new
rate one multi-key fully homomorphic
encryption scheme
as mentioned previously current
solutions for multi-key foley
homomorphic encryption will incur a
multiplicative polynomial blow up in
lambda
uh and our new rate one multi-key fully
homomorphic encryption
will asymptotically be just an additive
overhead rather than a multiplicative
overhead
let's start by discussing the round
reduction
the first tool we're going to use is
laconic function evaluation which was
introduced by quack we and wix
in laconic function evaluation
the right party will compress a large
circuit into a small hash which it then
sends to the left party
using this hash the left party can then
encode their input x
and send this back to the right party
then
given this encoded input
the right party can decode the output of
the circuit on that input but learns
nothing else about the left party's
input
to see where this will be useful for
round reduction let's consider the last
two rounds of our basic protocol as a
reminder
in the last two rounds the parties are
going to compute their encrypted output
and then
partially decrypt the other party's
outputs
so the lfe circuit that we're going to
encode
is going to have hardwired into it the
transcript until round to n minus 1.
this is all that is known
when you're constructing your messages
for round n
since we have not yet received the round
end messages
as inputs
the
circuit will take in the last round
messages as well as the secret key of
the party which received the lfe
hash internally it's going to compute
the lfe hash sender's input or output
and then it's going to partially decrypt
with the
receiver secret key
and that's going to be exactly the
output
of the circuit
the
sender's output which is partially
decrypted by the receiver
then we can send this hash in round n
alongside the
last set of messages for the encrypted
insecure protocol
and in around n plus one uh the parties
can then use
the hashes that they received in the
previous round to encode their inputs
given these encoded inputs the parties
can then
decode the output
of the circuit which is precisely
the result of the last two rounds in the
basic protocol
in the case of two parties we can shave
off an additional round by anticipating
the messages a little bit better
so instead of sending the messages in
round
n
we're going to send the
laconic function evaluation hashes in
round n minus 1.
of course up till this point we only
know the transcript until round n minus
2.
and this slide is from party one to
perspective so party one will also know
its uh round n minus one message because
it can compute that from the
uh transcript up till this point it will
this will also be hardwired into the
transcript
or into this circuit
then after receiving the hash circuit
party 2 will input its message n minus 1
which it just sent it will compute and
input its
last round message n
and then it will also input its secret
key
internally
the circuit will compute party one's
message n in order to complete the
uh overall
transcript
then use this transcript to compute
party one's output and partially decrypt
um the output with party2 secret key
it'll then output party one's output
which is partially decrypted by party 2.
and at this point party one can
finish
um
decrypting
all right finish the previous protocol
it's worth noting that we can't do a
similar transformation for the
multi-party case
because this crucially relies on the
fact
that party 2
can anticipate
its own messages
however if we were to try and do this in
the multi-party case party 2 would need
to know the round end messages for all
the other parties not just itself and
party one
in order to get a perfect round
preserving compiler for m parties we're
going to have to uh turn to obfuscation
so the obfuscated circuit that we're
going to use
is going to allow the
lfe hash sender to compute the lfe input
themselves non-interactively
so hardwired we're going to have
the parties secret key
and the input is simply going to be
an lfe hash which you've received from a
different party as well as the round end
messages
then the output is simply going to be
the encoded lfe input for that hash
and as a reminder
the
input for the lfe consists of
your secret key as well as the last
round messages
so we can then send the obfuscated
circuit at the same time as the lfe hash
and this saves a round
so given the obfuscated circuit
you can then
compute the other party's input to your
lfe
locally and then decode everything
however there's a problem with this
construction
an adversary even a semi-honest
adversary can now evaluate the
obfuscated circuit multiple times using
different nth messages and use this to
learn about your inputs
to solve this
we're going to add a commitment a
succinct commitment to your input in a
previous round say n minus 1
and then around n you'll prove
succinctly that the nth message is
consistent with the committed input
the obfuscated circuit will take in
this succinct proof
and only evaluate itself if the proof is
accepting
well i'll note that we can't directly
put the witness into the obfuscated
circuit
since the witness includes the committed
input and that committed input might be
very large
there's an additional complication with
using snarks since they only
computationally fix inputs
we can't actually use
indistinguishability obfuscation
instead we're going to use a token-based
obfuscation approach which consists of a
garbled circuit and witness encryption
the witness encryption is going to
encrypt the various uh labels for the
garbled circuit so that the
evaluator can retrieve just the labels
that they need for their
last message
and to do this
they can use a snark which proves that
their nth message was computed according
to the committed input
once they input the snark to the
appropriate witness encryption
ciphertext
they can decrypt it to get the garbled
circuit labels for that nth message and
then they can use those labels to
evaluate the garbled circuit
the security guarantee we get from
the witness encryption
is any labels corresponding to nth
messages which don't have a proof
can't be opened
we do need to be a little careful though
because witness encryption only provides
security for false statements
since snarks and the succinct commitment
can only bind the input computationally
it could be the case that two different
nth messages
can be proved
and if this is the case then the
adversary could acquire two sets of
labels which would break the security of
the garbled circuit
in order to solve this we're going to
need to use some extractability
assumptions
and specifically
the existence of extractable witness
encryption
using this uh the argument that the
adversary can't open two different
garbage circuit labels is roughly as
follows
assuming that they could
uh then they have to know
snarks proving that each of those nth
messages were consistent with the input
this is due the extractability of the
witness encryption
then in turn
the snark argument of knowledge property
means that the adversary must know the
witnesses which show that the nth
messages were consistent with the input
this witness includes an opening to the
commitment so the adversary must know
opening two different openings to the
commitment
we'll note that the input here includes
the randomness so this is what the
adversary is committing to both the
input and the randomness used in the
protocol
and that fully determines the
last message
so if they do open up garbled
garbled circuit labels which correspond
to two different last messages
then they do know the openings to two
different committed
input and randomness sets
moving on to the plane model
we previously needed the common
reference string
uh for the multi-key folio homomorphic
encryption our rate 1 construction uh we
also needed it for the volconic function
evaluation and in the
perfect round preserving compiler for
multiple parties
we needed it for
the snarks
in this
semi-honest
setting
we can actually just set any party to
uh sample the crs in the first round
then once we have that crs we can sample
our keys for the rate one multi-key
fully homomorphic encryption
uh and then in round two and and then in
round three we can key swap into the
rate one multi-key folio homomorphic
encryption
up until that point though we need to
use some different encryption schemes
in the first round we can just use a
symmetric encryption scheme which has
rate one
to encrypt our first message
however in order to transform this into
the second message
we need to
key swap into a plain model multi-key
fhe scheme which might have low rate and
the key swapping is simply done by
encrypting
the symmetric cipher text underneath the
plain model mkfhe
and then running the decryption circuit
using the encrypted secret key for the
symmetric scheme
we do incur a polynomial blow up in the
second message
due to the use of the plain model mkfig
but we don't incur any other blow-ups
[Music]
in terms of any of the other messages
moving towards malicious security
uh let's consider the case of
semi-motion security where the parties
still have to follow the protocol but
they're allowed to choose their inputs
and randomness on the fly
in order to
try and gain information
what we're going to do here is we're
going to divide the protocol into two
pieces
we'll have the pieces of the protocol
which don't require a crs
and the pieces of the protocol which do
it turns out we can actually replace the
crs for the rate 1 mk fhe with a
distributed setup procedure which just
takes one round
we adapt that distributed setup
procedure from burkerski at all and it
has security against even malicious
adversaries
then for the rest of the
components which need a crs
these are only needed later in the
protocol
so we can just use a generic two-round
semi-malicious mpc without increasing
the number of rounds
slide only shows the construction for
the round n plus one compiler but
similar ideas hold for the round end
compiler
moving to fully malicious adversaries
which can deviate from the protocol
arbitrarily it's well known that we can
make any semi-maliciously secure npc
into a maliciously secure npc using
universally composable non-interactive
zero knowledge
however we do need succinctness so we're
going to need to use
snarks
and simulation extractable snarks are
good enough we don't need full universal
composability
however snarks do need a crs of their
own
and this would blow up the crs
generation protocol to four rounds if we
used a maliciously secure solution
since we need the crs for the snarks and
the lfe by round n
we can only compile insecure protocols
which already start with five or more
rounds
and this would give us a total of six
rounds for the compiled protocol
this is not terribly satisfying since
four rounds is optimal for
multi-secure mpc in the plane model
using a black box simulator
to solve this our observation is that we
can actually use the crs early as long
as it's not revealed publicly
what we're going to do is we're going to
go back to using the two-round
semi-malicious crs generation protocol
and then we're going to wrap everything
involving the crs in a plain model
mk-fhe which uses new keys
uh it's perfectly fine for this plane
model fh mk fhe to have a low rate
because everything that involved the crs
already had a
multiplicative polynomial in lambda blow
up
then
once we've received a proof of
semi-malicious behavior in the crs
generation
we can decrypt
the portions of the transcript involving
the crs
and this will
provide security because we know that we
have security against
semi-malicious
behavior in the crs generation
of course since such proof would already
take four rounds
and we need next round to decrypt
we
are instead going to use a conditional
disclosure of secrets to reveal the
key for the crs portion of the
transcript
and once the all the parties uh prove
that
they behaved semi-maliciously
the conditional disclosure of secrets
will
reveal the secret key
for the
crs portion of the transcript
immediately so that will happen the last
four rounds
and at the end of that
all the parties will be able to decrypt
the crs portion of the transcript and
then finish decoding the transcript
now that we've discussed our
round reduction tricks
let's move to our other result which is
the construction of a rate one multi-key
fully homomorphic encryption
for this we're going to follow a
paradigm for rate one foley homomorphic
encryption which was introduced by
burkerski at all as well as gentry and
hilavi
we're going to
apply it to the multi-key setting though
the paradigm uses two tools the first is
a rate one multi-key linearly fully
homomorphic encryption scheme
and the second is a multi-key fully
homomorphic encryption scheme
with a linear decryption procedure
the fully homomorphic encryption scheme
is allowed to have
arbitrarily low rate
the idea here is
normal encryption under this scheme
will simply be to
encrypt your message underneath the
fully homomorphic encryption
this is going to be
a large result in a large ciphertext
then we can compress that large
ciphertext
by
keyswapping into the multi-key linearly
homomorphic encryption scheme
we can do this because
it allows linear evaluations of linear
functions and the fully homomorphic
encryption scheme has a linear
decryption process
you'll note that
once we have compressed the ciphertext
we can only do linear evaluations on it
in order to
get back fully homomorphic
evaluations
we can make an additional circularity
assumption that allows us to safely add
the encrypted linear secret key to the
public key
then using this whenever we want to
evaluate a non-linear function on a
compressed ciphertext
we can simply key swap back into
the foley homomorphic encryption scheme
evaluate the non-linear function and
then recompress
i'll note that multi-key fully
homomorphic encryption with linear
decryption is already known our main
technical contribution here is the
construction of a rate 1 multi-key
linearly homomorphic encryption
to construct this we're going to extend
regev scheme
to pack arbitrarily many messages into a
single ciphertext
as well as support multi-key evaluations
of linear functions
the message space is going to be ada
elements of zq where q is an even
integer
the secret key will be
a random
ada by n matrix
where n is a parameter which is chosen
both for security and for
efficiency
the public key will consist of two
components the first will be a randomly
chosen matrix of
dimension and by m
where m is similar to e to n
a parameter which is chosen both for
efficiency and security
and the second component of the public
key is going to be
um
s times a plus some error matrix e
to encrypt something under the public
key
we'll have two components to the
ciphertext
first we'll have a times r where r is a
random
length m bit string
and then the second component will be b
times r plus little omega times uh the
vector of messages
and here little omega is a constant
which is typically q divided by two
decrypt
we're going to round um
the second component minus the s times
the first component to the nearest
multiple of
uh
little omega
for the linear homomorphisms uh there
are two pieces first we need to
get an additive homomorphism between two
different ciphertexts which are
encrypted with the same key or with
different keys
and our observation here is if we keep
the first component of each of the
ciphertext
we can combine the second component
then
decryption
will simply be to take that combined
second component
and subtract
the
respective first components minus their
respective secret keys similarly to the
regular decryption process
the second piece of achieving linear
homomorphism is to
allow multiplication by constants
of course multiplying by a large
constant could saturate the noise
of the um
ciphertext which would prevent us from
decrypting correctly
the standard trick to resolve this is to
use a bitwise representation of the
messages being encrypted
and this will ensure that
multiplying by a large constant doesn't
saturate the noise since we're able to
multiply just the particular components
and scale everything
in order to achieve rate one
we do need to be add a few more things
first you'll probably notice that
the evaluated ciphertext scale with the
number of keys which are involved
however we can amortize this out
by computing on larger message spaces
this is particularly effective
when we're considering compiling
insecure protocols
which scale in
message size
with the number of parties involved
the second piece of the puzzle is to use
a ciphertext compression algorithm from
burkerski at all
and this is going to compress uh
multi-key linearly homomorphic
encryption uh or
ciphertex
by making use of the fact that um
the modulus q is even as well as
the multi-key linear
uh homomorphic encryption
uh decryption procedure
is also linear
you should see their paper for more
details
then using these two observations
we can make some careful parameter
choices to maximize their effect in
order to finally achieve rate one
if you found the talk interesting
and want to learn more please check out
the full version of our paper